hey guys what's up we are back with
another monster
parison video and this one will be all
about the comparison between Toho's 2016
shin Gojira and most of us 2019 Godzilla
we will include stats like size powers
speed agility other abilities and even
evolution being a fan of the idea of
Godzilla itself I can't really say which
one will win in a fight since both of
them have their own ups and downs but
what I can say is that you will have a
profound idea about all there is to know
about both of these magnificent
incarnations of the big G so before you
continue on with this video be sure to
like share and subscribe for more
related content and also check out our
channel as we have more than 70 videos
and all your ado smash the notification
bell for regular updates so let us get
on with this video showcasing to you the
comparison of 2016 shin Gojira versus
most diverse 2019 Godzilla origins most
of us Godzilla is explained to be an
ancient life-form from the Permian
period as the planet pool and its
natural atmospheric radiation began to
decrease he adapted to survive various
extinction events by diving deep into
the ocean and consuming the planet's
natural geothermal radiation in a
hibernation light state from its molten
core until 1954 when a nuclear submarine
woke him up whereas in Shin Godzilla
Godzilla is not far from nuclear origins
ghazal is not born out of the dropping
of a nuclear bomb but rather out of
nuclear waste dumped in the sea godzilla
like most monsters if not all is a
monster that humans make directly or
indirectly we later learn that it was
created when a marine animal consumes
nuclear waste dumped by the u.s. in the
sea once again nuclear waste and victims
lie at the origin of Godzilla design for
the most of us incarnation of the
character his face is cheap very
squarely with a broad neck and possesses
gills that enable him to stay underwater
indefinitely his eyes are yellow color
and his teeth are small his nostrils
bear more separate than the other
previous incarnations with them being in
opposite sides of the snout Godzilla's
head and neck design seem to lean
forward more than any of his previous
designs
dorsal plates are smaller than the
previous designs but they still retain
the core maple leaf shape in Shingo
jeera his fourth and primary form is
reddish and considerably taller than the
others and draws heavily on the
appearance of should I go G featuring a
rounded head with small beady eyes and
dark bumpy skin
Godzilla's fourth form possesses a
larger black maple leaves shaped dorsal
plates which run up from the top of his
neck the middle row of the plates is
larger than the others and is flanked on
both sides by at least two smaller rows
size legendary confirmed that they're
2019 Godzilla steel is 582 feet long his
height is taller at Trier at 93 feet
tall they are exactly 89 dorsal plates
running down on his back and a palm of
his hands are 34 feet and 4 inches each
and that his roar can be heard from 3
miles away
loud enough to make an opponent go deaf
this incarnation of Godzilla is the
heaviest and biggest live-action version
weighing almost a hundred thousand tons
Shin Gojira has five forms in total the
second was 28 meters tall 122 meters
long and weighed 150 tons his third form
was bigger at 57 meters tall a hundred
and sixty eight meters long and weighed
fifteen thousand five hundred tons
Shinto jiriz fourth form was both the
heaviest Toho Godzilla weighing 90 mm
metric tons and is the longest with a
total body length of 333 meters or a
thousand feet long and a height of one
hundred eighteen point five meters or
almost four feet tall next we have
evolution while retaining the same basic
design as his 2014 appearance godzilla
received a slight revamp for a king of
the monsters with his dorsal plates
changing in shape instead of being
jagged and straight in design the new
design features more pollution the three
large central dorsal plates
running from the mid way down his back
are the same shape as the original
Godzilla's dorsal plates the claws on
his toes are also longer and curved his
skin is rough in texture the tip of his
tail is also more rounded also his eye
color is now red orange but it also
changes when he uses his atomic powers
becoming bright blue or yellow orange
much like his attacks
Shingo jiriz appearance changes multiple
times over the course of the film due to
the creatures incredible evolutionary
capacity the first form only shows its
tail during the beginning of the movie
it's large and very much resembles the
second form snail in regards to
aesthetics being yellow hue with a
freight end the first form did not have
the physical nor physiological
conditions to withstand being on man the
second form is very much reminiscent of
a moray eel or frilled shark having a
long body neck and tail while also
possessing stubby underdeveloped hind
legs for land movement and stops on his
chest that I showed to be underdeveloped
arms the third form is bipedal with
stronger more developed hind limbs and
ability to assume a stance much like
modern Godzilla possessing small four
limbs and a long neck in relation to its
body the fourth and final form of
Godzilla is very much akin to other
traditional designs being fully bipedal
with a fully developed row of dorsal
spines and a much taller height in
comparison to his prior forms the shear
skin for this form is much darker black
in color with red glowing highlights
around exposed areas of the body such as
his neck back and legs
physical abilities Godzilla of the
monster verse is freaking awesome as a
lean mean fighting machine he can make
short Sprint's as seen when he was
fighting King Ghidorah and given his
size and the surrounding buildings he
passed by during his short run he would
have reached speeds of more than two
hurricane ohms as per our underwater he
can outswim most modern-day warships as
he was stated to be swimming at speeds
of over 40 knots
most of us Godzilla was also pretty
agile for his size as you can see him
fighting used all of his four limbs and
also a tail swipe this version of the G
man acts like he has been under training
with mr. Miyagi going to the other
corner Doh shin Gojira in his fourth
form of slow and sluggish in his
movements he was seen moving at a
snail's pace throughout the movie in his
fourth form one can't say anything about
how flexible he is or if he can even use
his limbs in a battle against another
monster but his third form can swim
pretty well as his earlier forms but the
fourth one seems to be entirely
terrestrial in nature although I believe
he could dive in for a swim if he wanted
to Godzilla is able to physically alter
his body and methods of attack based on
his aggressors as well as personal
necessities next factor intelligence if
most of us Godzilla was real he'd be one
of the most intelligent creatures on the
planet
this Godzilla things and strategizes
admit combat with massive pay off he is
able to calculate the exact position of
the male mutants location to get him
with a direct final blow tail strike and
uses some fighting techniques created by
human beings Godzilla is also able to
express massive amounts of emotion with
very few animals being able to do so he
can appear exhausted angry determined
and even be determined enough to stay
alive and become burning Godzilla to
kill Ghidorah later on
Shin Gojira rather than being openly
heroic and tanky mystic or some shade of
gray in between in this movie he is
outright detached from everything in the
world emotionally with this he shows no
outright intentional hostile expressions
it is possible that this Godzilla is a -
force of destruction
Gojira zombie-like demeanor is only
broken when bunker-buster bombs drop on
his back physically harming him Godzilla
also displayed some intelligence as it
reserved some energy in order to
surprise attack the squadron of Japanese
workers who attempted to inject it with
a coagulant
next comes durability what is the
maximum hit or damage most of us
Godzilla can take where he was dropped
from the upper atmosphere like a bomb
only to rise up again and defeat King
Ghidorah
in his burning form he can also
withstand conventional weapons fire
during tank fire and missile barrage is
one unique aspects that instead of being
destroyed by nuclear weapons he can in
fact absorb the power to himself and
become even stronger Shin Gojira
regenerative abilities however proved to
be the most potent that any pieces of
his flesh can break off in bodily parts
grew to starfish like creatures this
enables him to reproduce asexually
through either fishing or even
self-mutilation Godzilla is also immune
to virtually any conventional weaponry
barely seeming to notice when he is
attacked
however massive ordnance penetrator
bombs that struck Godzilla directly on
his ass pose back were able to injure
him and cause him to bleed albeit the
loss of blood didn't seem to impact his
performance second loss powers as if an
indestructible height massive intellect
and raw power are bad enough Godzilla
has another secret weapon that makes
every other attack weak in comparison
his iconic atomic breath godzilla uses
his atomic breath in combat more
frequently against king ghidorah
although it is still not his primary and
most powerful attack Godzilla utilizes a
more powerful version of the attack in
his final battle with King Ghidorah in
Boston but then after absorbing Mothra's
energy in addition to the nuclear energy
already absorbed from a thermonuclear
explosion
he became burning Godzilla and in this
form he annihilates the false king with
two nuclear pulses which are equivalent
of hydrogen bomb explosions in Shinto
jira Godzilla's atomic breath changes
according to how he uses it and
indicates how much power he has used up
on firing it it starts with a super
thermal flame and in later develops into
an atomic ray that resembles a focused
purple energy beam that Godzilla spews
out and the effect of it has
overwhelming destructive power that does
not simply crumble nearby buildings but
is powerful enough to slice through
multiple skyscrapers on whim Godzilla
can fire a volley of atomic rays from
his dosa plates this lasts for quite a
while before he transfers the energy
back into his mouth and the tip of his
tail finally enemies and barrels
most of us Godzilla has a lot of
opponents on his feet his first win
chronologically was against the Shi
Nomura
he then fought against a male and female
murrow's in 2014 and at a bit later in
the same year he defeated mucho prime
and in the last battle he fought several
times against the alien tree headed
dragon Titan called Ghidorah until he
finally won against him in Boston of
course his next fight will be against
another title called Kong which would
become a two-on-one fight against
Mechagodzilla in the end shinji Adira
however has had no battles with other
gigantic monsters in this universe and
the only opponents he has been against
was the Japanese and the United States
military paying respect to the original
Godzilla this one was also set against
the human population of Japan as a
monster born from nuclear waste so even
though he doesn't have the impressive
kill car of monster vs. Godzilla he
still battle hard enough against
humanity but then again he was defeated
by them but so was most of us Godzilla
when you think about it when he was hit
by the oxygen destroyer
anyway we have come to the end of the
video and it is up to you to battle it
out in the comments section on which
what will win if they were ever pitched
against each other in battle
most of us Godzilla has the advantage of
size I'll be the small one
durability agility and a nuclear pulse
but those could still not be enough
against Shin gojira's laser-like atomic
breath and his spinal blasts as well as
his tail beam Shin Godzilla is also able
to physically alter his body and methods
of attack based on his aggressors so the
winner of this fight is still in the air
anyway subscribe and yeah hit that
notification bell